si senta media 95 grammi di crudo non
c'ero prima io è che numero a 27 io 25
sono qua da due minuti e mezzo rispetti
il suo turno maleducata dicevo crudo me
lo fa molto sottile quasi impalpabile
che se non mia figlia non me lo mangia
poi mi sono 75 g di bresaola alla devi
iniziare nona non lasci perdere almeno
troppo stopposo inizio non mi piace
senta ma km zero che cosa sono la
ricotta vaccina c'è un supermercato così
importante che non mi alla ricotta di
capra km zero ma che vergogna
buongiorno mariangela tutto bene è vita
e da fighetti di vinta niente prende due
cosine per accomodare ma allora fanno i
400 g di cotto poi fammi 400 g di judo
c'è un po di grasso di enti tutto buono
e metti metti teresa maria angela faccia
eparina teresa offro io e resa non
scherzare assolutamente è che mi offendo
lo faccio con piacere vi saluto quando
volete è passata al villino e vi offro
la cena il caffè e la merenda quello che
volete